what's going on what's going on it's
your boy Deontay Hitchcock AKA Mary Tate
Blige AKA Tammy Campbell and you can
catch me on the bootleg Kev podcast run
it up
black cat podcast special guest in here
Deontay Hitchcock you're representing
Atlanta Georgia right so these mods like
actually work I got talking to the mic
well it's just like for sure I mean if
my guy over there is doing the uh job
you should do it okay he's handling the
handles over there you should be able to
just get comfortable man so what's up
buddy all right can I call it it's good
to see you I don't know if I dm'd you a
couple years ago
listen bro I got a T-Pain like story we
were going back and forth with each
other I was like you got to come I saw I
think I might have saw your bars on 995
freestyle or some [__] yeah
I don't remember the DMS I'll be doing
drugs what kind of drugs you do actually
I won't be doing drugs no more but I was
saying drugs like shrooms and [__] like
that so do you want to do shrooms right
now no I do not okay no I'm about to
have some I have a child now I mean I've
given me even more of a reason right you
actually very right but no
you stop doing shrooms because you had a
kid I stopped doing shrooms my last time
doing shows was New Years for this year
I feel like I got I got everything I
needed from that trip I mean how much
did you eat I want to say four or four
point five see over anything did you get
serious uh but by that point I had done
shrooms enough times to be like okay
it's not that wild of a trip type [__]
right I mean it was a good time what was
the last one like
I was damn near the shaman for all my
folk cause my little brother did she
kind of putting everybody on yeah about
to kind of make sure everybody trip was
good and in that instance it just felt
like all right I'm here I've done what I
needed to do type [__] it just felt real
gotta Amityville for me oh wow it was a
good time just a little bit closer just
a little bit closer pause
um
so have you done the heroes dose ever
Heroes dose I think that's like six
grams a little bit I don't know I like I
like life as it is you know what I mean
you ever done DMT no would you try it
not at this point in life alright so
once all my [__] is handled and all my
bills are like automated one day yeah
about to say once I know I'm not feeling
like tweak out or I can tweak out and
it's okay cool not yet what about
Ayahuasca so I've heard about this [__]
I'm not really privy to everything about
it they said it's like some real ancient
[__] I don't really [__] with like yeah
so you're supposed to do it with a shot
man yeah it's supposed to take like a
it's kind of like a day I feel like I
gotta like mentally pray for that like a
lot of people go to like Costa Rica yeah
like Peru and I'm fighting demons still
I can't that's we're supposed to get the
demons out yeah but I don't know man I
don't know you drop it no I want to for
real I've only done mushrooms I'm scared
to do everything else I want to do DMT
so I want to do DMT but the one time
that I actually had real DMT in front of
me I pushed out man my boy John John had
it ready to go and I was like man I'm in
this hotel room with one of my dogs in
San Francisco I don't know if this is
the spot bro I don't know if I want to
do DMT in her in my in at the end
yeah so I haven't done either I want to
do both but you know DMT like it's kind
of like uh it looks like you're smoking
crack because you have to freebase it
anything with a pipe I'm straight on bro
yeah they have like the pens but that
shit's not supposed to hit the right way
you're supposed to actually like
Freebase it like you're smoking's a rock
you know I had that [__] that they say
it's like it's like the last thing your
uh
yeah when you're born like what makes
your life flash for your eyes I'm
straight no you can smoke that no I'm
good hey man people smoke a lot of other
[__] you know what I mean not sure it's
real I'd rather smoke that than fentanyl
you
fishing uh anything dislike
so I read this is this true your uncle
co-wrote No Scrubs so all right so my
uncle used to make music right okay he
the one who started me making music
after I had an interview with uh Rob
Markman at the time yeah shout out to
Rob he asked me this question but then
he said somebody else's name and I was
like damn has my uncle been lying to me
all these years because he didn't know
who the [__] I was talking about when I
was talking to my uncle my uncle told me
about this [__] all my life he still
claims this [__] all the time so in my
eyes yeah he wrote it but he said
somebody named like Shaggy or some [__]
like that I don't know nothing he's
saying no more but yeah my uncle wrote
it he helped yes yes so did he like
Marlon Hitchcock Marlon Hitchcock yes
sir so so he's who got you like kind of
interested in getting into there yeah
but so he started me doing [__] like if
he didn't do music I'd probably be
somewhere like skating right now or
dancing or some [__] so are you a
skateboarder I went on skateboard I was
like an inline roller skater oh you're a
roller skate yeah I was in Atlanta like
we all escaped
yeah yeah until they close it down it's
a car dealership now damn trash bro I
feel like there's not a lot of skating
rinks that just anywhere anymore nah I'm
about to say we still got like all right
so for us it was I was on the South Side
so it was like sparkles it was a Skate
Zone now I'm sorry skate time it was
like on that Skate Zones like Mount Zion
but still Skate Zone skate time still
there that close Sparkles that's the car
dealership and [__] now but we still got
Cascade and that's on the west side we
still got like Golden Glide we still got
like sounds like a Vibe go to clock with
five that's something I low-key sounds
like some lube
some Magnums in a bottle of that gold
you might have to go down get that [__]
sponsored
all right if we go to Atlanta
um
okay I'm gonna just preface this
conversation by saying I had the wings
at a
King of Diamonds not King of Diamonds
City and they were very uh overrated to
me especially doing is cool
um what are what what is the best let's
take the women out of the equation if
we're talking strictly cuisine
what is the best strip clubs in Atlanta
just to get some food to get a bite to
eat at how about something I ain't the
biggest strip club connoisseur but I
might say he'll tell you gotta have
cheetah I feel like ranks number one is
that the place with the lamb chops they
got some lamb chops they got Simon
flavors they like Nickelback and like
like if I say it's real real GTA is yeah
me I mean it's like I heard they got
great food yeah Simon played Crazy
um actually cool
plus a blue flying actually has some
nice food I heard blue flames got better
Wings than matches yeah if I saw blue
flying school it's cool that's what I
mean that's according to Killer Mike
Onyx is gone
yeah if I say nah that's the three have
you ever been to the Claremont Lounge
nah where they have like old ladies and
midgets yeah no I'm about to say I like
midgets though
attempted to take us there one night and
he was trying to like [__] with me like
bro I'm gonna take you to the hottest
strip club in Atlanta
images
I mean I ain't got no problems with them
okay cool all right and by the way
I'm not trying to get canceled that's
right that's right that's I feel like
they're my people say they can't counsel
me it's been uh two or three years since
you dropping last time I was like 20 20.
so yeah three years coming up on three
years before the Panini why'd it take uh
so long Panini The Panini yep the
panoramic whatever you want to call it
what about the pandemic threw you off
your creative tracks bro
I feel like for a lot of folk like I
just uh posted about this [__] the other
day that I like we dropped our album
that album Better was what may the
pandemic started in March and I'm gonna
say we dropped the album in May so it
was like we can't do [__] right now no
touring no nothing like torn is what I
was looking forward to the most out of
like I did six tours before I put out my
we went out with Rhapsody went out with
jig black Wale jidenna and Le Kelly 47
out of [__] with no album so I gotta say
at this point we put out my own gate
like when we getting ready to put it out
back from like [__]
all that in the world shut down I think
me and mariba had a show and then that
night everything shut down shout out to
Marie yeah about seven River five
um but yeah I feel like it was just a
weird time for everybody though like
crazy that [__] felt weird it felt empty
yeah I mean I'm just doing shows on
folks couches and it was like bro I'm
tired of virtual shows okay so you were
just kind of what you were doing like
virtual shows yeah yeah I'm about to say
me me and raps
I remember everybody was like I had
homies like investing in like virtual
concert venues like this was gonna be
the new wave I'm like bro this [__] is
trash but Nate's had to make it shake
somehow like there was like what's going
on Indians doing stand up on Zoom like
Zoom is out of this [__] it's dark times
it's a wild time bro dark time stop and
then during the pandemic you end up on
the dreamville project that was before
the person yeah yeah but I thought that
was 12. that was nice summer of 2019
yeah I think we had actually this [__]
is like very condensed like [__] don't
even feel real and by the way the
pandemic feels like it started like six
months ago still to be very like all it
feels like that [__] happened in the
blink of an eye but it's been three
[__] years that's crazy all right bro
I looked up and I was like bro I got a
job so technically a Grammy nominated
yeah I'm not you technically no you are
yeah we win that [__] but Grammy
nominated put that on the resume like a
little certificate yeah it should have
grew you gotta frame that [__] what yes
she's sitting in the crib right when you
walk up the steps the plaque right there
with the certificate right on it you
don't see that [__] did you um you know
shout out to mariba you mentioned black
Jed the whole like spillage Village
Family yeah did you kind of come up with
them in Atlanta at the same time no
actually they're a little bit older than
me so
first time I really like got privy to
them anything I was down in uh school I
went to Georgia so that's like three
hours away from the city and you
remember like were you here to like the
edge was moving and all that [__] so you
had like key two nine yeah of course the
SoundCloud [__] exactly man so out of
that [__] was really bubbling while I
was down there at Southern so I would
come back home I think I first time
being black was on the Edgewood in the
Edgewood parking lot at random well he
still had the goddamn lots and all that
[__] was like I met a [__] around three
blacks one of my favorite options but
I'm crazy crazy yeah one of my partners
like came up with him that I met in
college and he was putting me on his
[__] back when he was shooting with a
dude I think his name was like blue 22
or some [__] like that but yeah man made
random walking down Edgewood that's
crazy crazy I don't think that that that
uh movement gets enough credit for like
kind of kicking down the SoundCloud
doors I think of like father and kid
those guys were like kind of like the
first guys that I really kind of
discovered through SoundCloud I'd be
wondering what the [__] happened like
when I what the [__] happened just why
Kia ain't got like the respect he
deserved I don't know there's a lot of
those unsung heroes because there's like
some guys in like Miami like uh Space
Ghost purpose somebody else who kind of
like had a lot of like come over like
influence yeah with like kind of like he
kind of yeah and like you know I feel
like there's a lot of those kind of guys
from like the blog sounding loud era
they don't really get the it should be
working
the flight or a lot of [__] got I saw
key with it first that's some real [__]
a lot of [__] that's like key fire I
wrestling y'all go check your [__] out
so you uh you met black in the parking
lot at Edge would you say random Museum
like right across the street from
department store all right apartment
stuff who would you say uh would be your
like two or three influences as an MC
that you could point to
and life
[Music]
wine Wayne off top yeah which what's the
best Carter too I like cartoon yeah I'm
not saying caught the one right behind
it Carter three is amazing whatever I
say in the first two just classic how
about something crazy
um
Andre
for sure
who else
who else would I say certainly not nas
listen man look bro shout out to Nas I
need somebody to put me on
the right nine songs to listen to
because like I got a cousin who swears
up and down the knives is the greatest
rapper alive he can rap
um we just can't take that away from me
that's definitely better than Lil Wayne
see that's what I don't know man I don't
know if it's a regional thing but you
from Arizona Arizona
bro you're from the West Coast like Doug
like how what
I don't know ask the question I listen
to your medic it was like it's a good
album but maybe folks over hype them to
me and there's no disrespect or not I
don't know it's written nah but so we
that's what we talked about hey people
that yeah still matter like beats bits
and pieces of each of those if you ever
listened to rewind yeah
I mean little Wayne's never written some
[__] like that bro but he's got more bro
it's more when you say more so more is
not always better I ain't gonna say more
is always better yeah quality over
quantity okay more quality he has a lot
of Misses as well but we ain't got too
much bro okay so
Carter three amazing Carter two wait
wait wait wait wait wait so we're
talking about 2008 is when the Carter 3
dropped
no wait
oh nines No Ceilings yes 09's in the
first No Ceilings
the hardest four can we agree that the
Carter 4 had some singles but was mid
yeah okay there's a lot of sheets around
it
you weren't bumping the rebirth were you
I actually did a lot of rebirth yeah I
say Prom Queen on Fire come on okay I
know
I Am Not a Human Being you're bumping
that how about somebody uh right above
it I mean he has some singles okay okay
by the way very slept on album Like
Father Like Son shout out to Wayne the
Birdman that's classical army guns is on
that [__] by the way I'm saying
classic to me because we just had this
whole classic [__] thing and your boy
on the couch is over there like God this
guy's saying a lot classic to me
personal classic like father like son is
amazing I love life my life is so soft
if somebody told me it wasn't a classic
I couldn't argue with them type [__] but
um I just feel like after Carter after
No Ceilings I just feel like the Wayne
[__] kind of just fell off a cliff but
it's so much [__] before that bro
everybody from 04 to that period at 09
bro you couldn't go anywhere without
saying I don't think we've seen
well besides Drake at this point now at
that point in time there was no one who
had a more aggressive run than that I
agree
no as far as like like length as far as
your length a quantity with the mixtapes
yes very light it was insane I was like
we ain't never seen no [__] like that
and it's put out four albums in the last
three years and two of them got Grammy
nominations you think this Nas Run field
I'm just saying it's not I'm saying he's
got errors in his runs it's not for sure
I definitely respect the longevity of it
all because a lot of folks can't 2009's
debut it was like 19. well he was on
live from the barbecue main source and
93 I believe that's that's when I was
born so he been rapping for as long as
94. I could be wrong on the main source
what year it was it might have been 92.
and that's amazing I mean like I would
hope to be rapping 30 years down the
line type [__] I would hope to still be
able to and still have a fan base my
thing is he was he's been rapping all
that time again out of nowhere him and
hit boy just catch a [__] wave
I just
it ain't for me how about so I haven't
no one's played me a song where it was
like I feel like I need to invest it I
think you like it was written I'm gonna
check it out when we leave it like I
told you if I don't [__] with that one
or the uh uh what was the
but oh no no let's not even put those in
the same discussion bro all I was trying
to tell you was that Eminem has put out
an album recently that wasn't dog [__] I
fee so listen the Eminem album music to
be murdered by is a good album it's his
best album in like 12 years now I'm not
putting that in any sort of same
discussion as
It Was Written okay I was just saying
like because we're talking about off the
mic we're talking about our goats and I
was like I'm not sure Eminem could be
considered the greatest of all time with
the amount of shitty music he's released
which is also my argument for Lil Wayne
um
I don't know man this is too much though
sometimes sometimes sometimes with
little Wayne it was too much wasn't it
no no I mean too much in the best
possible way pig bro it's about after No
Ceilings it was just a lot of mid he
gave it straight he gave us at that
point it's live ending everything else
is in the game and Nikki exactly
everybody say all that other shit's
negated at that point anything post 2009
it was
different so would you give Eminem the
same benefit of the doubt
so I was just he gave us 50. I was
younger when uh Eminem's real run was
going on okay side by side I wasn't as
preview I wasn't like when Wayne was
doing that [__] I was like what
14 right so I was really that was my
entry point to music type [__] was like
that's what I'm really getting into so I
saw that as a child it was like that's
where I want to be like I like that type
[__] Eminem I think I was with
seven seven eight when it was first
going on so I wasn't really that I'm
tapping in like that okay so I don't
know I went outside for that one
fair enough
y'all bootleg Kev here man got
a sponsors at King Palm baby got a shout
out to them and we're welcoming them
into the new family man of course uh we
treat all of our partners at the bootle
cat podcast like family shout out to
King Palm man if y'all don't know about
King Palm they are the leaders in the
smoking industry when it comes to their
tobacco-free blunt wraps no nicotine no
tobacco just good old leaves all right
yeah that's right um and look their
product that I love are these right here
now these right here are the pre-rolled
tips you just stuff them with your your
herb your cannabi that you get from a
Hardin and uh
they got these terpene and flu infused
uh tips now what they are is you put
your wheat in there all right you hit
the [__] little pinch on that thing
and you get to burst the flavor now
these are the red reins which is like an
energy drink flavor obviously they got
the Strawberry Shortcake which is also
gas now this is what's dope too there's
just so many lines of these rolls uh
shout out to the leaf tubes you can get
these blueberry these big blue grape
Fusion joints so much you can get man so
many products uh check out your local
7-Eleven your local smoke shop all that
but you could also go to kingpom.com
right now and get everything online
delivered right to your door for half
off 50 off if you use that promo code
bootleg that's right shout out to King
Palm man we're talking about essential
smoking uh when it comes to like just
getting that Clean Smoke it's not too
harsh or organic you ain't putting
nothing crazy in your lungs you know
what I'm saying shout out to King pong
no tobacco no nicotine just straight
look and I gotta shout them out too
because
can we take just take a good look at
this
you know we got multiple sized King Palm
hitters over here
I think right there is like a goddamn
Jesus
that's a [__] boy right there you
know what I mean shout out to King Palm
that's a king pong Leaf right there
stuff with some fire some fire all right
so look right now you're gonna want to
go to uh kingpom.com uh use that promo
code bootleg get half off whatever you
need smoking accessories Leafs some of
these awesome uh pre-rolls that they
have that you just stuff your stuff in
stuff your stuff in you know what I mean
um kingpom.com 7-Eleven your local smoke
shop all that make sure you follow them
online at King Palm and check them out
speaking of stuff that you're stuffing
shout out to my bookie man my bookie you
already know mybookie.ag I'm riding with
the Phoenix Suns God damn it them Sons
going all the way uh if you are like me
and you like to uh you know put a
friendly wager on some sports
which I do a lot I've been using my
bookie for about 10 years now uh you can
go do the same thing right now now this
is what's dope about my book you go to
mybookie.ag it's the online sports book
not only is it an online sports book
they got the Blackjack they got the
whole Casino situation craps roulette
whatever you're into you could play it
right at mybookie.ag and if you use the
promo code bootleg when you sign up
bootleg you'll see it down below
[Music]
when you sign up you'll get that first
deposit bonus now get a new account
mybookie.ag when you sign up bootleg is
the promo code first deposit bonus up to
a thousand dollars you put in money they
give you money it's that simple all
right there's so many ways you can win
money of course they got NHL right now
the playoffs are happening in hockey if
you're from [__] Canada and you care
about a terrible boring sport also
basketball NBA playoffs are booming
right now put all the money on the
future for the sunset with a
championship thank me later I got Suns
versus Celtics in the uh finals also
baseball
another atrociously boring sport but a
great sport to gamble on all right so
what you're going to want to do go to
mybookie.ag use that promo code bootleg
right now and get uh your first deposit
bonus unlocked speaking of unlocked
unlock your [__]
go to bluetooth.com right now
it is summertime if you're dealing with
elect erectile dysfunction Ed if you
will maybe you got stress at work maybe
you're tired of looking at the same
chick
maybe you just need a little pep in your
step
um you need to get on that blue too man
you don't need to do anything but it'd
be nice to have the option to so go to
bluetooth.com right now
use the promo code bootleg and get the
first month supply of Bluetooth for free
what is Bluetooth
well Bluetooth is a chewable gets
delivered to your door in a discrete
package no doctor's appointments no
doctor's visits and uh it has the same
active ingredient as Viagra
and Cialis
so we're talking about getting your dick
hard here in case that went over your
head you know it won't go over your head
once you take it I promise you that all
right Bluetooth also is uh incredible
because not only does it come in the
blue chewable flavor with the same
active ingredient as vibrancy house but
it also has a mint chewable flavor which
is the same active ingredient as Levitra
all right all this if you're questioning
I don't know I don't want to spend no
money on does this [__] work look yes it
works and you don't have to spend money
if you use the promo code bootleg at
bluetooth.com because it's going to get
delivered right to your house they're
going to give you a month's supply for
free you just got to pay five dollars
shipping that's it the bluetooth's come
into your house no awkward doctor's
appointments
no awkward doctor's visits it's all
online
bluetooth.com thank me later thank me
later let's get back to the interview
Drake or Wayne
now like today all time all the time I
still might give it a drink Mr Drake
that run has been the same bro that's
why I was saying like before Drake I
don't think we had seen anything like
that post Drake yeah [__] bro we just
talking about this in the car who's
listening to some of his music Brisbane
I don't think he's left the charts since
he came in no he hasn't that was 2009
bro it's 23 now bro it is 14 years
straight just the number one guy 14
years
yeah it's it's kind of crazy what's your
favorite Drake album
this is best rap album yeah
shout out to Clinton Maryland
bro come on man all right
y'all got like ads on here this is
perfect time for ad to pop up well Drake
owes me fifty thousand dollars so I'm
gonna until he pays me my money I don't
know we need details you can't roll past
that he was there
fifty thousand dollars yeah we made it
back
we made an NBA bet in 2021
and uh you ain't heard from him since
yeah Ah that's [__] up first time
you've ever heard come on right Freddie
Gibbs was there we were sitting at the
bar at the at the uh Harriet
and uh he told me that the warriors were
gonna go further than the suns in the
playoffs and I said put some money on it
he said 50 000. I said all right and
then we went to the finals for that man
bro it's all good man I mean it's like
all day you gotta pay that bad
no idea no
I definitely DM them and was like hey
man I don't know if you're I don't know
if you remember but you won't need it
feed the bank job to Drake though he's a
nice guy and I've come to peace with him
being
a top seven all-time top eight all-time
game this top five Hendrick's above him
for sure
so this this is interesting I love
Kendrick as well me and my partners be
having arguments about this [__] all the
time like I think they're really
negative dog I feel like they give folks
different things for sure but I feel
like each one is just as important as
though because you know we were talking
about uh who has five classic albums and
it's definitely Kanye right but you know
who's right behind them yes Kendrick's
right there I just don't I just feel
like bodies of work I'm just like
Kendrick doesn't miss because if you
think about like to pimp a butterfly
when that [__] first came out a lot of
people hated it because it went above
their heads and their [__] musically
weak-minded [__] they're very shallow
fans but like that album aged so well
it's like such a great album like I like
it a lot more I think it was interesting
like when it first dropped me and my
whole girl uh my best friend stays in
Trinidad so I went overseas with her
type [__] and a lot of the people over
there we were talking about we were
having like debates about Cole Kendrick
drinking all that [__] and he had
recently just dropped the pimple
butterfly and a lot of them didn't
understand it right because a lot of
things that he's talking about is really
like us-based United States and I didn't
realize like how different the world
view on [__] like that is and that kind
of threw me a little bit that's why a
little um a little good kid Mad City
shot a little damn I love all the
[__] actually I don't think
about it section 80 crazy
how about so I ran 80 HD up so many
times you know how Apple got the [__]
where it plays the uh song with a first
as soon as you get in the car that [__]
played so many times my [__] bro I never
used to stop on me never never I feel
you know why because I started off as an
Android guy
so I had Spotify look I got both now and
not the same I have both phones you know
what I mean I finally I would never ever
like I'm keeping my iPhone forever I'll
get rid of the Android at this point I
don't know what I was thinking this
whole time man the cardo was for you it
was because I was like wait what happens
if I already have an Android do I still
get the album the only thing I don't
like about Apple music is how they try
to put their YouTube album on
everybody's [__] bro I still haven't
listened to it but YouTube app no
YouTube they oh you oh yeah yeah every
every album every every iPhone has the
[__] YouTube that was the same type
of [__] where you just buy an iPhone and
it counts as YouTube going diamond or
something hold on hold on so that [__]
automatically counted towards the sales
yes oh yeah bro I need to talk well I
think they got rid of the all those like
yeah so it's gone now the merch bundles
and [__] crazy
I mean not a bad idea like hey buy a
hoodie you're gonna buy the hoodie
anyway if you buy the hoodie it comes
with a free album it's great and it
counts towards my shoes and it counts
yeah and it counts man
um so let's talk about this new album
you just dropped this new record whoa
yeah which is fire thank you very much
um you got big crit on the album yeah
well it's on the album Big Creek wish I
had Boogie uh I'm home girl shamba
is it Shelly or Shelby it was Shelly
okay yeah not like the Mustang no
how about yourself so is he back his
drum yeah
because I was [__] confused yeah I
think you did the rerun because of
insanely talented guys who actually fell
asleep during an interview we did once
all right he was so high he passed out
during our interview it's on YouTube
shout out to drugs I was like
I was like am I tripping her shout out
to Drake you can't be offering folks
rooms I didn't offer him shrooms
all right yeah shout out to drugs again
drum's a very talented guy though
amazing so drum crit Westside Boogie
um you familiar with dende
amazing artists I'd like to say he just
had some [__] that go went viral
probably like last week from that
mistake he did like an uprox performance
she was crazy
um
[Music]
as well how about another talented
singer yeah but yeah I think that's it
for you like uh how intentional are you
with like bodies of work because
nowadays everybody's so [__] hung up
on like singles and like just dropping
different Impressions on the algorithm
and not really focused on like
cohesiveness when it comes to their
projects before I answered I might have
tweet I can't remember if I said my
proud of Dave David Fuller's also on
there as well amazing singer
um but as far as albums I feel like it's
different now like it's a different time
bro like albums aren't they don't feel
as important as they used to be I mean I
still take pride and like putting one
together he gave me an amazing one
because I feel like you still got folks
who listen to it for that and the folks
who stay with you like your fans for
life listen to bodies of work and it's
like it also almost counts as like a
checkpoint where you are in your life
like a Time marker type [__] with the
folks who don't listen to albums fully
they're just gonna make their own
playlist anyway right they're gonna take
their favorite [__] and put their
[__] together I think that's
what we are but I said he'd be trying to
tell me all the time like
making a classic body of work is
important but at the time period that
we're in now it's more about just
feeding the people in general they'll
make whatever album that they want with
the [__] that you put out right so
that's why you see for like NBA young
boy who dropped where he dropped like
eight projects last year though she's
insane yeah it's pretty crazy yeah I
think like it's like I think though
whenever we think about like the greats
still today
we always go to their Pro we talk about
their albums still yes but
but I feel like they had a different
type of Grace when they came up that
might be fair because we look at them
that way and like the people the last
greats that we always talk about is like
Kendrick Cole and Drake and the last
three greats right now and I still feel
like they came at a point in time where
we were still in but I think even little
baby like I think people look at my turn
and they're like damn he actually came
out and [__] dropped a body of work
that kind of like separated him from
everybody else everybody else in his but
until he dropped that he didn't have the
like before my turn he was dropping
consistently oh yeah he was on his [__]
so he couldn't afford to not drop until
he dropped a body of work and he already
had all that attention so it's like it
made sense yeah and I get it so it's
like especially now for somebody who's
trying to like cut through the noise and
break into it I don't think we have I
mean the the luxury of not dropping who
do you think are the excluding uh the
names we just talked about Cole Kendrick
and Drake who is the let's say the last
five five years who who do you think are
the new goats the new ghost hmm I don't
know it's interesting man because I feel
like there are a lot of a lot of things
a lot of parameters and boxes to check
for [__] like that like I feel like we
got a lot of people who are extremely
lyrical but haven't necessarily had the
breakout hit example mainstream a lot of
my favorite lyrical artists right now
about so you can go for G you can go for
Kenny Mason you can go for everything
it's a lot of Hometown people for sure
extremely but I think we're all trying
to get to that next level yo man this
last legit I'll miss amazing
album of the year last year when I did
my best albums I put it above uh I put
it above Kendrick's album last year
I feel like a lot of folks were having
that back and forth debate that [__]
Thomas [__] right about to say uh what's
the Cody blue [__] that's my favorite
song the swing on this one that's my
favorite song uh what was the um
the [__] is it I'm trying to think of
the name of that song which one
is the word crackhead in it crack
silence crack sandwich
fire he's one of the best rappers now I
agree I mean but I think like like I
said a lot of us are trying to get to
that next point it's like I feel like a
lot of the lyrical people now with this
uh jail whether it's asaba where there's
a reason what is any of these guys like
we all have very Niche fan bases but we
all want to be like I feel like a lot of
the people that we look at as
Inspirations is like the Wayans is the
Kendricks and the Drakes and all of that
I feel like they did the same thing that
we're doing but they also had the hits
hits they also had the mainstream [__]
that [__] to pull people in and I think
that's what we're trying to get yeah I
think jid's just missing like that hit I
mean obviously he had that big record
with Imagine Dragons and like I put them
in front of a bunch of new eyes but I
just think like you know that breakout
single yeah it's like his own to me he's
like right dude but I think little
babies like yeah blue baby's amazing
he's I think he's the guy the last five
years he's been around I don't think
nobody's [__] baby bro man he don't
win on to some of our favorite folk song
and I wrapped him for sure I feel like
he had rap cold I feel like for sure
Drake for sure
he washed Drake went crazy
Jesus on that little that what was that
a three pack Drake drops yo little baby
skated right here everybody liked it and
he's like we've seen him like I don't
think we've ever seen somebody get so
good so fast
because I think like when little baby
first came out
you were like I hey
no I liked him too but like I feel like
like he was very limited as like a
Lyricist and like he would openly talk
about how Gunna helped him like become
like with his rapping and [__] but now
I'm like yo this guy's just
impeccable or anything you do every day
you're gonna get good at he was in the
studio non-stop I feel like there's a
couple folks from Atlanta like that
right now though because 21 was the same
way true I like 21. she really loved 21.
yeah I love 21. I'd love when like him
and Metro boom and [__] it's just crazy
Savage mode one and two Jesus that two
nuts two's the one
I agree and like I think 21 Savage like
kind of like found his pocket yeah and
it's like
can't beat Atlanta bro
hey man what's up guys hey um if you are
watching this and it's April 20th 4 20
I'm gonna be hanging out at Jardine
today
that's right put the flyer up The Rock
I'll be at hardeen um hanging out all
day today
um the craziest most just luxurious
illest dispensary in the world located
right in Los Vegas Nevada now Hardy in
Las Vegas they are our family they
sponsor the podcast I love those guys
dearly and when I say that it is the
best place I've ever walked into to buy
premium cannabis I'm not lying best
customer service
best bud tenders best bud
put in your King Palm
and uh just overall man just a great
experience um so what y'all need to do
is go follow them online hardeen
underscore Las Vegas follow them on the
gram
we got a lot of dope stuff in the works
they actually just opened a a fire
podcast studio so we're gonna be doing a
lot of content in Vegas
live from Hardin they also just dropped
a [__] tennis shoe with Fila they got
dope fly gear
um man premium cannabis the best
selection
culture
sniff you walk in that man listen they
got I'm not even lying to y'all Harding
has their own signature scent and it
smells good I keep a bottle of it in my
car literally maybe twice a day I spray
that get that hard eating whiff smells
amazing so look make sure you go to
hardine uh if you're in Vegas get in
that Uber get in that cab as soon as you
touch down say take me to hardine the
taxi drivers the Ubi drivers they know
exactly where it is because it's the
hottest spot in Vegas they go take you
straight there you're gonna tell them I
sent you they're going to get you
situated real nicely all right Harding
underscore Las Vegas go show them some
love go to hardyandlasvegas.com gotta
give a shout out to our oh geez my dogs
had Odd Socks baby they've been [__]
with us from day one
um and they've been dropping so many
crazy dope new like socks you know first
of all can we talk about Beavis and
Butthead they just dropped the Beavis
and butt head socks and draws let's take
a check just a nice little peek at the
Beavis and Butthead
oh
come on man
they also just dropped Coca-Cola we got
Scarface we got Reese's we got the big
[__] Lebowski so many dope socks the
most comfortable socks in the world the
most comfortable underwear in the world
and check this out right now you can get
20 off that's 20 off at checkout at
oddsoxofficial.com using the promo code
bootleg so go right now
otsoxofficial.com my first uh suggestion
would be get you a pair or a pack of the
Odd Socks Basics the black and the
whites those are my go-to's and then you
gotta [__] with some of these Big
Lebowski socks and they just got
Coca-Cola
they got the Scarface boys like what are
we talking about man what are you
waiting on they are the most comfortable
socks in the world
um so if you're not wearing Odd Socks
you're just cheating yourself you know
what I mean you're really cheating
yourself
they got [__] South Park
come on bruh what are we talking about
go to oddsocksofficial.com right now use
the promo code bootleg save 20 off at
checkout on the most comfortable socks
in the world or don't and keep torturing
yourself with those shitty socks you're
wearing right now
be a damn shame anyway let's get back to
the interview it's been like what 20
years since you guys have just been
holding on to this [__] since trace it
sounds nice
has it been since then damn near I
really feel like it started with like it
really started with like
snap music type [__] nah nah nah I'm
gonna say about it crunk juice no no no
Ahmadi was the king's a crunk [__]
King's a crunk that was like
2002. something like that yeah what's
the [__] get low and all that [__] I
feel like after that [__] it was just
over yeah
because then like like Luda [__] is Tia
T.I easy yeah yeah Amigos
shit's insane it ain't going nowhere no
time zone
it's too much going on bro
right yeah where do you put the Migos in
your top rack groups of all time
number one I'm [__] it's cash for me
it's gonna be outcast I don't care we're
talking about like I think we did this
before too we had an argument about like
this Outcast have more hits than the
Migos I think they had bigger ones I
think hits hits
I had a lot I guess may have like a
strong hold on 15.
I think the Migos man had like 16 17
with the outcast Outcast hits way bigger
yeah Migos don't have a hey yeah no wore
roses or anything like that but they do
no but they do have uh bad and boujee
they do it bad and boujee nuts so but
they don't have
I feel like most of the hits uh they
don't have them it's like sorry Miss
Jackson like yeah I think Outcast has
the bigger records but
I mean at this point
The Amigos might be I mean you know what
I'm not gonna say that because I do feel
like Outcast kind of burst
a lot of
what I love about Atlanta hip hop in the
last or even Southern hip-hop
so they did influence a whole generation
of guys to be like lyrical and dope and
but damn Migos like influences they
influence Drake also you can't talk you
can't take nothing from either group but
everybody so that's my 1a1b
who's the best amigo
all right I don't want to say it just
because he's passed and I think I'd say
I've been taking that's like I've
supported for the whole time you ever
see the take off La leakers freestyle
when he was on the with the one with all
of them was on there yeah that's how he
was going crazy that [__] was so tough
or his Cadence was insane oh he was
insane and it's crazy because like when
the Amigos first came out I do feel like
takeoff was like the Duke carrying the
[__] early [__] you know what I'm
saying he was the rapper well they've
all had like their runs as well guys in
the group that had the wave going you
know what I mean look that Beyond I mean
not Beyonce is quavo it's like the
Beyonce's group early on because it
seemed like he had like the most
Charisma about so the most swag he was
usually the dude on the hooks so it's
like that's what I hear most type [__]
but when Tyga reverse was coming in bro
and then also you know he was locked up
for the early half I feel like offset is
kind of like the best of quavo and Tyga
if he's like I feel like he's the most
well-rounded me of the Migo I ain't mad
at it and I heard his album that's
supposed to be coming out whenever they
let him come out that [__] is fire for
real oh my God the offset
whenever offset is allowed to drop his
body of work oh
gotta hit it it's crazy I believe yeah
he delivered for sure yeah yeah shout
out to the Migos so you got is it Miko's
number two rap group of all time I don't
care about I said Migos right there for
me how about so it might be Atlanta Vice
but let's say you know I say my uncle
put me on like UGK and all of them I
ain't never get too hip to like Wu-Tang
and all that yeah and then like my mama
told me that was crazy man yeah I think
it's like Outcast Wu-Tang
Tribe Called Quest
those are the three friends like they
was putting me on like a Midnight
Marauders [__] because when I first met
them I hadn't heard any trap sheet and
then you can get into like the mob deeps
the Bone Thugs the Migos the there's
like a whole list of guys after that but
I think Migos in the five yeah Migos up
there for sure bro I don't think it's
another group modern day I said most
success number
yeah nobody about so she even going to
the Past yeah like it's not too many
groups just had more success than Migos
100 man uh when's your album dropping
made sense May 10th May 18th so we got
21 days are you gonna make everybody
wait for three years for another album
no actually I ain't gonna get a date or
nothing for the next one but we outside
all year that's all I'm saying so you're
gonna keep You're Gonna Keep this this
pressure coming so I had once I had my
kid I had to go down sit down for a sick
write my mind right off the street take
care exactly yeah I mean
shout out to black fathers we out here
hearing me all of that [__] I was at the
house now
back outside I had a pickle woman who I
knew was going to be a great single
mother at the time came shooting me like
it's gonna be a great time but she got
it
you had to pick a woman that you felt
like would be a great great single
mother nature and she has all the
quality she's gonna be good when I'm on
the road she got it I love you baby
this is your lady yes oh okay yeah I
just feel like the way that came off was
like no I was like I've been [__]
around but I did not like you because I
mean obviously I'm gonna leave her
because
it makes you should be all right
but she's good yeah me are you finally
gonna be able to scratch your tour itch
yes bro like that [__] was what last
tour was
2019 yeah wale that was the last one no
I'm sorry jidenna it was the last one
ain't been back since
I do think jidenna is a pretty wildly
talented guy for like the he should be
bigger than he is because I feel like
he's very very uh he's he's he's like
incredible yeah but so classic members I
feel like it sucks when like your first
song is like that big it's almost like
people don't give you the benefit of the
doubts and like go dive into your
catalog and [__] because like people
more people know the song and they know
you exactly and that [__] happens with a
lot of dope artists yeah yeah it's a
hard thing if I say it's a good problem
to have but it's a problem all the same
it's like the gift in the curse of your
first song being uh
songs and it's crazy too because that
song doesn't necessarily like really
like represent like his sound exactly so
it's like a stash the top part yeah
because it's like if your first record
was something like that was like more
true to like what like if I listened to
your album was because you good yeah
classic man it's almost the [__] that
you make doesn't go crazy but Doja cat
uh it was the [__] same thing
it's like the [__] you [__] around on
it's crazy it blows up who was that who
initially invited you to the dreamville
sessions
[Music]
all I remember was the first day I saw
folks dropping their golden tickets I
was pissed because I ain't getting one
the first day oh I got mine the second
day yeah but I remember calling him
specifically and was like bro I gotta
turn my [__] up because I was mad
because it was in Atlanta and it's like
Brianna came all the way out here it
didn't attack exactly nothing it's like
next day I got that [__] were you around
when uh I heard that Chris Bosh was
making beats bruh
Chris but all right we in a room
smaller than this for real how about say
from about that section of the while
we're sitting in that [__] it's
a chair right here it's a door that
swings but the way the door open when it
closed I mean when it's open you can't
see who's behind that [__] and it
literally took the person away but
somebody close the door and literally
was like who's that back there making
beats we turn it's Chris Bosh you've
been sitting in this room for hours with
us sitting back there making beats and
nobody even really nobody knew Chris
Bosh nobody knew Chris Bosh was in the
corner of the room making beats how were
the Beats shark actually Were You There
When the bucks came yes they bought
everybody Donuts they brought everyone
Donuts great people you get to talk to
Giannis Yes actually he's talking [__]
he was yeah I can't imagine he just
seems like such a sweet guy he's got a
Disney plus movie totally [__] oh I
thought you said he was talking [__] no
no you don't know about the tallest [__]
I mean he's tall [__] on a smooth five
five on a good day so that's like
looking him it's crazy yeah you are
short I didn't realize that when you
first watched it the midgets of my
people bro we can't cancel me bro I'm
right here yo great size though for
stage diving a crowd surfing they're
true very true compact yeah get a job
done have you ever done that no I was
planning to do this [__] on my first
tour
there it is man well look the new album
comes out May 10th yes uh
appreciate you coming through I
appreciate it being go stream the album
when it drops the single whoa is out
ASAP I might say play that [__] run that
[__] up you have to pay I got a kid to
feed play that [__] let's go man you
already know Deontay appreciate you
pulling up brother I appreciate you